part of the jury mentioned that
innovation is in Carnegie Mellon's DNA I
think people have accused me of having
Carnegie Mellon in my DNA because I grew
up around campus and I in some sense
I've never lost a spirit that Carnegie
Mellon really is and I think that the
wonderful thing about this panel is it
really reflects the kind of innovation
in brain mind and learning and the
interdisciplinary work that you really
see nowhere else in the world accepted
Carnegie Mellon which is why I'm at
Carnegie Mellon not because of my father
so I want introduced to people on the
panel Tom Mitchell who is a computer
scientist by training but is
collaborating with many brain scientists
Mason urban was a neuroscientist by
training but as much computational work
and boskar who's a temper or alumnus but
did work in artificial intelligence and
has also studied implications of law and
an artificial intelligence and marlene
Berman who is a cognitive neuroscientist
who's also done a great deal of work on
translational work in how brain injury
can impact our lives and how we can deal
with those types of issues and the other
thing I'd like to say about this panel
and I just want them to get started I'll
ask the first question is that these are
four of my favorite people in the entire
world two of them I known for almost 20
years Marlene and Bhaskar and they're
both marvelous people to talk to that
I've always had wonderful conversations
about these issues with and two of them
Nathan and Tom I just met the past few
years but they've rapidly become again
two of my favorite people and I just
really cherish the kinds of
conversations we continue to have and
what happened to the future and it's
again so uniquely Carnegie Mellon that's
such a diversity where people all talk
and think about some of our problems
okay so I want to ask them the first
question and is Marlene said this is a
deep question it's not necessarily an
easy question I think we're gonna start
with Oscar and then we'll let it sort of
freeform from there but I will cut
people off appointed people and try and
get them to move on so many of you I'm
assumed of heard about Watson and Watson
played Jeopardy quite well Eric Nyberg
who's a faculty member in language and
Technology Institute of Carnegie Mellon
and one of the creators of Watson said I
think it's fair to say that Watson
represents a sort of new high-water mark
in him from
systems in the sense that it can
pinpoint answers for us with speed
accuracy and confidence in a way that no
question and to existent could before so
computers keep getting smarter and
smarter and maybe it's a good thing
maybe it's a scary thing I'm not so sure
but the thing that puzzles me it's a
brain scientist I think we all think
about is how do we know when computers
are actually intelligent and what are
this what are the sort of standard by
which we say a machine is intelligent
like a human being or not and another
way is thinking about it looks like I
sort of don't have a good answer to what
I keep pondering is when there'll be an
ethical question whether or not we're
allowed to unplug Watson okay it's not
this when he complains it's got to be
deeper than that okay and so that's my
first question to the audience will
start with Boston we'll take it from
there thanks Michael
I'm glad to be here I should explain
that I'm the only person here who's not
actually a CMU faculty member I would
give a lot to be a CMU faculty member
but I had to say that since I left CMU
in 1978 I've always felt I have it much
better
I must see a mural um and very glad of
it I and I like the question it's been
asked in one form or another for a long
time for 50 years people have been
saying AI isn't possible they've been
saying you know this system that you
describe it's not really doing what you
say it is or they say you know even if
it did this it's not really intelligent
people have deep uncertainties about
what constitutes AI especially people in
in Boston there are lots of people and
there are people at MIT whom gotten into
fisticuffs with those people and so on
but I want to sort of reach for the CMU
answer so I'm going to sort of start
that and then see how far we can go into
it so what does the CMU answer you know
when I was a graduate student herb Simon
was the face of CMU for me
he was my thesis advisor
and I would meet him for an hour a week
and we would talk about the research and
then it was time for me to go and I
would be packing up ready to leave and
then he would hold up some book you know
it might be a book on nonlinear
differential equations or on temporal
logic and once it was a history of the
tang dynasty and so I figured it out
what I was expected to do was to show
interest in the topic borrow the book
read it bring it back and discuss it and
so I was supposed to do that so that's
the answer you're going to get a student
in nai lab who was first poor fellow to
discuss the Tang Dynasty with an advisor
who was a political scientist who
invented artificial intelligence there
there you have it so when is it okay or
not okay to unplug a computer you want
it maybe you should incapacitate it you
want to fire it from a job you want to
imprison it you want to put it to death
those are the kinds of questions and
these are hard questions and very
important it the kind of fun to talk
about but they're not just fun they had
people have answered them people have
answered them angrily
they've had implications for funding in
AI and they will have implications in
the future so when I think about this I
reminded of one of the most awesome
exchanges in the history of film that
most of you in this room except perhaps
some of you 21st century types would
would have come across and thinking
about this video David Bowie is stuck in
this pod 500 million miles from Earth in
a little pod no radio contact all his
fellow astronauts are probably either
dead or dying and he says open the pod
bay doors Hal and how in that amazing
scary voice flat unemotional voices I'm
sorry Dave I can't do that
and
sometime later about 20 minutes are half
an hour into the film Dave puts Hal to
death and so the question I have you
answer a question with a question and I
hope to come back to this but this is a
question I'd like you to think about
would you be willing to be Hal's
defense lawyer would you be willing to
have him to see him acquitted what kind
of a defense would you have for him and
there is a CMU answer it's not the same
as what I would call a local answer an
MIT answer or a Harvard answer there is
a CMU answer that maybe we'll get to but
the the thing is a guy here out writing
around the corner some time ago said
that he wanted a government of laws and
not of men and I'm certain John Adams
was thinking of AI systems when he said
that and the point is how do we make
that happen and all of you CMU graduates
are the ones who are going to make it so
Marlene Marlene can give us a biological
perspective on this perhaps I would say
that I have a more circumscribed
approach to this particular problem
because my own area of interest really
is human cognition and so for me it's a
really deep issue about what human
intelligence really means and how we're
going to define it of course it's a
perennial problem that has plagued
scientists like myself for a really long
time and I think that they've two
aspects that we need to consider in
thinking about the sort of the binary
nests of human intelligence versus
artificial intelligence and the one is
that it's not clear that intelligence is
monolithic that there is there are
cognitive issues this abstraction of
problem-solving and planning and
projection but there are other
of intelligence as well that I think
people are becoming to recognize more
and more including things like social
intelligence and emotional forms of
intelligence so when we think about the
comparison between human intelligence
and automated systems or machine
learning algorithm ik implementation I
think we need to consider beyond just
the cognitive approach and to think to
these other facets of intelligence as
well but even if we just restricted to
cognition which is the domain where AI
perhaps is played at the most it seems
to me that there the the discrepancy
between humans and machines is still
really fast I don't think we have to
worry yet about Watson taking over our
jobs or you know what's and really sort
of undergraduate yeah probably time to
unplug him okay so when I when I think
about what it really means what
cognition really means much of the air I
work in feel free to jump in has really
been conducted in close class problems
chess mess sort of very defined domains
whereas for me actually Senate Li in the
research that I do much of the work is
in a much more open complex environment
so for example one of the domains which
we cite often about how humans can ask
stuff even the best computers is in the
domain of face recognition so let me
give you an example can we look at slide
14 this is one example situation here
are just a couple of photographs that I
borrowed from some colleagues of mine
and it turns out I assume you can all
see to some extent that there are faces
these impoverished and rather sparse
images it turns out um
machines even some of the best face
recognition algorithms have a really
hard time seeing the faces in these
kinds of images maybe we could look at
the next slide as well and I'll give you
sort of a further example humans at
least the human face recognition system
the human perceptual system in vision
and this is in the visual system the
same is true in humans speech
recognition is that we can cope with all
kinds of variations I hope you can see
in the top row here that it's the same
individual whose face seems to change
over the course of the last time the
same individual looks somewhat different
from different poses in different facial
expressions with different kinds of
illumination and blur on the images the
human perceptual system is
extraordinarily good and robust at
extracting the invariance and
understanding whether this is the same
individual or not the machine learning
systems the algorithms even some of the
best ones that exist in the world are
not yet up to the standard so I think
we're still at a sort of humans one your
machines half maybe in this competition
I mean they they are gaining on us but I
think that the flexibility the
robustness the the immunity to
invariance in the human perceptual
system is something that will sustain us
in good stead for a while but you know
Marlene it's interesting because even if
you could build a machine that could do
this faster perfectly I didn't talk it
happily and we wouldn't need a defense
lawyer and I think in the domain of
capability I think you know it's still
humans one machines a half I'll give you
that but there's another domain from the
standpoint of this sort of more ethical
below that I think there's a question of
almost uniqueness if we build the same
machine two times and we give it the
same inputs we're going to have
effectively copies two identical
machines and I think there's something
interesting about the uniqueness of the
individual humans that I think that you
know bears considering in this kind of
context another thing that I think is
relevant is the fact that and maybe this
is related if you unplug the machine you
have a much better chance to be able to
restore it to that state again then we
do then what then we certainly could for
a human and thus I think there is
there's and that's important to me if
you're going to unplug me I wanna be
able to reach to be restored and then to
my current state I think there's a lot
that's going on minute by minute second
by second that sort of in the background
that is an important component that
makes me in my you know perception of
things right now different than it would
be you know for other people but also
for machines this sort of background
processing which is really important so
you're three Tom because I'm not so sure
that I bring to see anything well you
know the thing about all computers being
the same are kind of interesting I think
think about twins with the same genes
for example or think about a program
that starts off two copies of the same
program that start off the same way I
think just as twins can develop into
different individuals so could program
two copies of the same program if they
had different experiences along the way
and if unlike most programs they were
actually learning programs that allowed
that experience to change their
development in there but you know would
that be enough because it's actually
interesting question but I'm plugging
and plugging in because let's say later
on they plugged how back in and he was
perfectly fine and everything was okay
maybe it's fine to unplug him and plug
them back in there's something uniquely
human where you can't really do that
ever and you know so the something goes
deeper about the way human brains worked
and beyond just the state see I mean I
think that's a function of our lack of
understanding you couldn't do that or
whether that's something more
fundamental well it seems pretty clear
that the difference is really that
computer brains are portable you can
stick Miami machine you like and human
brains somehow or
your twine with his biologist well I was
thinking people when people criticize AI
the wizened bombs the dreyfuses service
the Penrose and so on I think they make
what I would call a mind bug a
conceptual error a CMU term and mind bug
is this they think that the way we
evaluate computer rights and computer
personhood is by comparing them with
humans you see I know how I start I'm a
human
I have personhood I'm sentient I'm
intelligent and I have an immortal soul
perhaps you think I had and therefore I
have certain rights they start from
there then I say well look there are
whole continuum of things chimpanzees
dolphins elephants cats cows dog worms
they all have to the extent they're like
me I say they have personhood and to the
extent they are not like me I say they
are not personhood and so I think that's
the basis a Kantian basis for having
computer rights but actually computers
don't belong in this continuum they
don't belong that at all I can't ask is
what some less than a cat you know
rolling around though so tom has his own
pet computer what he's very fond of so
maybe you can tell us about nell tom
because there's a case where he's got
person and i think back when mike asked
this question about the ethics of
turning off a computer yeah i was struck
by the fact that if he had asked that
two years ago my answer would have been
to giggle what a silly question but what
struck me about question is today i know
a computer that i really do not want to
turn off and i would feel bad if i got
turned off i'm not saying that i would
be put in jail with me but and i want to
tell you about this program because it's
it's a little bit different kind of
program this is a program we call nell
nell stands for never ending language
learner nell is now 17 months old
it runs 24 hours a day seven days a week
it its job
is to learn to read the web and every
day has two tests that we evaluate its
performance on one is every day it must
look at the text that's out there on the
web and extract more structured
information into its knowledgebase its
database and you know these are facts
like Oh Carnegie Mellon is in Pittsburgh
or water is the beverage or laughter is
an expression of emotion these kind of
facts so that's one thing it has to do
every day is extract more facts from the
web but more importantly the second task
it has every day is to learn to do tasks
number one better needs to learn to read
better than it could yesterday how would
you test that while you'd send it back
to the same text it looked at yesterday
and you'd see whether it extracted more
facts more accurately and if so then
it's done past two correctly which is to
learn to read better so that's been
going
oh here's the slide okay I have no idea
when that slide appeared but somebody
was okay so I don't know how well you
can see the bottom part of this slide
that's probably the most important part
this is a sample on the bottom part of
this slide of ten randomly chosen
recently read facts you can see the
dates there this week in June that
represent wet Nell has recently read on
the web and just in case you can't read
those I can barely Harry gamble Pavilion
is a tourist attraction that's the first
fact another one says Kim Stolz
is a female okay so and if you look at
that set of fats it's fairly diverse and
that's what Nell is doing up in the top
oh I see there we are
this plot shows the size of Nell's
knowledge as a function
of time I mentioned that Nell is now 17
months old so that plot starts in
January 10 and you see the accumulation
of knowledge you see this dip that's
because the first six months the program
was running we just went hands-off we
seeded the program by telling it
approximately 600 different categories
of information we wanted it to read read
about universities read about beverages
read about people extract relations like
which person plays on which baseball
team things like that
and for each of those we gave it a dozen
or so examples a dozen universities a
dozen athletes and since then it's been
learning on its own how to find more
athletes more beverages more relations
that of who plays on which team so this
is what it's doing that dip you see is
when we noticed after six months that
its accuracy was dropping and that it
needed just like most of us some
interaction with somebody smarter and so
like what we've been doing every day
since is spending five minutes a day
with no correcting it's a pretty bad
parent so I've developed an affinity for
now every day I spend my five minutes
and I find I get excited when it you
know I look at this I pull up a random
sample you can go to the web and pull up
a random sample yourself you can click
on the little thumbs up or thumbs down
to help nail yourself but I get excited
when I pull it up and it's alright and I
get a little you know it's okay but it
makes two mistakes
and I find so for me the question of is
it okay to turn off this program I don't
know the ethics of it anymore than the
rest of us do but I do know this I would
feel bad because I've kind of developed
it's kind of odd to say this in public
but I've developed an affinity
for this program and I want it to get
better I want to go back next to you can
see that it's not making the same
mistake you made today
great okay I think we're gonna go to
another question which is really the
subside of exactly they just asked you
and I think I had a new appreciation for
human intelligence when I had kids which
is relatively recently I have a four
year old and a seven year old and one of
the things become clear is that our kids
rapidly outperform even the smartest
computers around and face recognition
and language learning by age two the
kids are fluent and they'll still
learning it's not quite two yet but I
don't think it's gonna get there as
quickly as the kids so I was hoping
maybe Marlene you could start and talk
about maybe issues of why people were so
much better and maybe with reference to
creativity you can bring that in or
funny accidents that I think we may
infect be growing some potential
individuals who may win both a Nobel
Prize and a Tony so let me show you some
examples of some work that is currently
being done by students have seen you who
are in a whole range of diverse
disciplines but who are engaged both in
science and art simultaneously and let's
look at slide 10 please so this is some
work I will show you initially by a
photographer in the art department in
the College of Fine Arts at CMU Patricia
Marie Dee's she's involved in the
interactive brain project you can see it
on the left hand side and on the right
hand side R is an example of a
photograph there she is then she's
particularly interested in art and
biology and art and science and she
teaches a subset of CMU students exactly
at the intersection of science and art
if you look at the next slide you can
see an example of some of the really
beautiful work that's been done in this
case by a student from the computer
science department who is doing some
work in arts and as
this image really stunningly and
beautiful and really very creative and
pets in the next one you'll see an
example of of an art student who has
taken some some MRI images that we have
generated and sliced them up put them on
kind of plexiglass just as you can see
in the bottom and then put them in a box
and illuminated it from the bottom as
though this were sort of something of an
intelligent sort of sculpture in itself
so I think that there are at CMU
initiatives to really bring science and
art together and so maybe one day we'll
have Jerry Cohen standing here and
saying we've got Nobel winners and Tony
winners and some individuals who in fact
have been able to to garner both and so
the question is well what is this
creativity and while we can teach it to
our students
why can't computer said it could we
teach it to computers so this is a
question that I have for Tom maybe in
when I watched Watson performing I
actually think Watson's quite creative
and that's in an unusual session comes
up with error responses they really
humans would not come up with but some
of them are really quite quirky quite
sunny and quite quaint is this computer
creativity
what's creative if you I think if you
one type of creativity I think is really
connecting up fats that you didn't think
we're connected yeah and I think that's
exactly what Watson does in fact right
so it's got this tremendous volume of
facts sitting around you get a question
in those jeopardy questions demand that
you put together weird chains and things
if that's not creativity I don't know
what is well what about also though I
mean herb Simon used to love to talk
about insight so I mean what about the
whole I can computers new insight at
this pointer is it's something uniquely
human yeah well I could have an insight
on this I could try and channel but I
I'm thinking that this question has to
do with thinking that computers that
when we build computers we're building
approximate people and then all the
questions of Rights and personhood and
all those things keep cropping up effect
for those people so on but I want to
think let's think about computers
somewhat differently go around at a
different way rather than saying they're
humans they don't populate this
continuum so why don't we think about
something else that's a person that's
not on this continuum at all I know of
something systems that have that are not
sentient have no physical existence are
not even intelligent and then they have
rights and they have rights in every
society on earth even in the most
god-awful totalitarian societies
corporations have rights and preparation
corporations are our creatures and they
have rights not because they have moral
worth or because they are like us they
have rights because they're damn useful
with corporations we become richer not
just financially but culturally and
intellectually as well and perhaps
that's what we want all these AI systems
to do not to mimic us I mean there are
plenty of really interesting people
around but to do something on their own
the kinds of things that can protect us
from ourselves I would love to have an
automated Supreme Court I think that's a
really interesting idea and it makes me
realize that if we took a show of hands
of who would complain if they turned off
Google I bet we get a lot of hands you
know so there are programs out there
that are so beneficial to just like
corporations we want to give them
certain rights to persist right and it
may be that again the standards of what
we consider creativity or insight and
things actually have to be different
because there's things that are human
and things that aren't human but as
you've said maybe it's already creative
and interesting ways they can certainly
synthesize data in ways that we can't
necessarily do I'd like to sort of think
about this from a somewhat different
approach
again thinking about capabilities why is
it that the two-dollar calculator can
solve math problems that I can and from
my perspective one of the interesting
things and this gets back to my sort of
response to the earlier question is that
there's there's a biological hardware on
that underlies it and that biological
hardware works in a very different way
than the silicon hardware that underlies
you know that the route now and Google
and all these other things and I think
that by appreciating some of the aspects
of this biological hardware will
hopefully gain some insight into
function why it is that we can do face
recognition but also into dysfunctional
why it is that you know under certain
circumstances face recognition breaks
down or why it is under certain
circumstances we get you know
hallucinations or the sort of perceptual
disorders associated with say autism or
and and I think that thinking about how
the biological Hardware implements these
things and how it differs from the way
Silicon Hardware does I think is a very
important way to provide insight into
these kinds of questions which are you
know ultimately a lot of the ones that
drive certainly drive funding and drive
a lot of the work that we do so I'm
happy to say that you've all survived
the moderator portion of our show and
we're going to now 50 having questions
from the audience and what I'd ask is
that if you have it directed at a
particular person mentioned that person
if you want the whole panel to try and
take it and filled it pleased to say
panel answer this question and so we're
very happy to take questions from people
sorts of things
does anyone want to feel that okay I
understand I'm far from an expert but
about poker or about this project but my
understanding is that this is already a
problem for a lot of online gaming
gambling sites that they're they do
various things to try and determine if
the player quote-unquote on the other
end is software because there are many
ways in which I mean people want to
think that it's a fair fight
and certainly in terms of be able to
remember what cards have already come up
computers can win that so I think in
terms of in that strict sense I think
computers do very well in poker I think
the advantages that people gain by
having that's online poker the
advantages that people gain by having
sort of access to facial expressions and
other behaviors that's where I think the
computers as far as I know are still far
behind I mean one of the cognitive
abilities that underlie a lot of these
abilities like determining whether
somebody is bluffing or whether they
trustworthy is to sort of the current
thought is that you kind of run a little
mental simulation of it because you
can't I can't crack know what's in your
head I mean I don't I can't get into it
I don't have access to your thoughts but
what I can do is I can look at you
really carefully and I can very quickly
try and run a little mental mental
simulation if I were bluffing I would be
doing X and then I can look at you and
say well maybe you are bluffing because
you've got the same
I don't know fidgety nurse that I would
have if I were bluffing and so this is
kind of
it's in their idea to do this kind of
theory of mind as it's called to run
these mental simulations I think maybe
uniquely human I may be wrong well I
think that's when the challenge is I
would say is maybe we certainly don't
have automated systems that are able to
incorporate this and so I think that
this is sort of part of the the Kenyan
that will have to be crossed in order to
be able to get around to a level playing
field if we want to do that right well
of course the computer is expressionless
yes you'll never know if it's bluffing
you Michael to judge from the amount of
time that it takes to make a decision I
mean that's the sort of minimal
information that I think you could gain
and then of course the computer could
randomize that if it so chose so so I
would also say being a regular poker
player often it's not a matter of even
the interpretation of reading what they
call the signs or the tape Patel it's
more the context and the previous
pattern of that person and and so on and
so on and so might be possible to guess
well and that's if your computer is
consistent and that's something that
computers can certainly do the
chess-playing computers certainly you
know looked at every game that their
opponents had ever played and new
tendencies based right
so they're more like computers they're
more like computers
it's a great observation I think some of
the skills and strengths that we have
bring about cell ability in other ways
we are just you know just to return to
the issue of face recognition because
it's kind of a no-brainer and kind of
easy easy domain we are indeed wired to
recognize faces with very high
probability even seeing faces in clouds
and seeing I mean this is the TV
advertisement where they show you all
these faces like this the keyhole and
the steering wheel I mean we sort of see
faces everywhere because from a social
evolutionarily sort of relevant
perspective we should be wired that way
that's absolutely crucial for our
survival the problem is that it gets us
into trouble sometimes we tend to see
these patterns where they don't even
exist but I think from a survival
strategy it's probably that we make
these kinds of false alarms we sort of
over wired to do this because it will
ensure our survival rather than having
too many misses but this I really I like
I like the question I like the the
oddity associated with it question back
there
so I think I'll answer that I think I'm
gonna ask Nate's and answer that aspect
of that too but I want to say that
Carnegie Mellon has been a leader and
it's continued to be a leader in
biomedical imaging it's really one of
the exciting areas of strength and that
involved neuroscience imaging and other
kinds of imaging of the human body and
biological organisms and it's just
beginning where it is infancy and it's
already incredible we can do with MRI
but in the coming years it is going to
revolutionize diagnostic medicine and
aspects of neuroscience and treatment of
psychiatric diseases and it's really
going to change the way we think about
treating and understanding people at the
same time I want to come be a little bit
cautionary because I think that the lie
detector question is much more difficult
because it gets better Marlene's in
about theory of mind and understanding a
lot more than just what's happening in
the pattern of the brain into
understanding sort of the basic
principles of our cognitive systems and
I think we're a lot further away that we
are from that then having really good
detailed pictures of the way our brains
work so that'll be the first part the
problem is getting good pictures and
then we have to understand what we've
got when we've got these huge piles of
data and that's where people like Tom
come in and they can help us and
Carnegie Mellon's nucleus set up to do
that as well and I think from a
biomedical imaging point of view I think
there's other things he's been doing so
I didn't quite hear all the questions so
tell me if I didn't if I missed the
target but but I think the the ability
to see what's going on inside the brain
either in real-time as you mentioned or
even sort of post hoc is gives us
tremendous insight there's a person in
my department in the biology department
who has pursued tools to try and allow
this to happen her name is Allison Barth
and so what she did is she recognized
that it would be really useful to be
able to take an animal on her case a
mouse trained it to do something and
then to be able to identify which not
only which parts of the brain but which
cells in which parts of the brain are
the ones that changed or were changed by
the process of that learning so once you
identify which cells of the you know
hundred billion cells in my brain if we
could know which ones had changed their
properties changed their function when I
learned something that would provide us
tremendous insight so what she did is
she developed a novel genetically
modified animal that literally has cells
in it that turn green when after
learning after they are changed in the
course of learning and so this allows us
to find the needle in the haystack so to
go from a situation where we have no
initially no idea at a fine scale which
cells are modified and now we know which
cells were modified and we can start to
ask the question of how they have
changed how individual cells are changed
by experience that's just one example of
the ways in which imaging approaches
which really combine the technology of
imaging with in this case the molecular
techniques that allow us to develop new
probes new genes and putting those two
things together is I think absolutely
critical for understanding both normal
behavior memory and also abnormal
behavior disease in the context of the
brain I just want to add another
dimension to this also the if by
bringing in computational methods like
including especially machine learning
methods to analyze these kinds of brain
image data what we're able to do is well
this Nathan mentioned that the wonderful
thing about brain imaging is we can see
where the activity is and we some of
these other techniques we can see where
the changes are but it's a lot different
to see where the activity is and to see
where is the information coded in the
brain and so what we found we can do by
using machine learning methods is that
we can essentially build virtual sensors
of where the information is and we do it
like this we have let's suppose we
wanted to know where in the brain is it
that you're thinking of a screwdriver
when I show you when I show you the word
where is it in the brain that's coding
the information about whether you're
thinking about the word screwdriver or
the word house for example so what we
can do is we can train our computer
programs by showing it here's some an
example of a
image or even more locally the brain in
bitch for the left half of the brain
when somebody's thinking about
screwdriver here's the different image
when they're thinking about house here's
another one for a screwdriver here's
another one for a house and the program
can learn the pattern of neural activity
that differentiates those things and
what we found is that by playing on that
idea and expanding it we're now able to
Train computer program classifiers to
detect all sorts of different
information hundreds of types of
different information in that brain
where does your brain when you think
about screwdriver where is it that your
brain thinks about how you would grasp
it where is it that it thinks about the
aspect ratio of the screwdriver and
we're starting to have ways of seeing
not just the activity but which parts of
that activity code different features so
it's when you bring in this kind of
computational method it amplifies the
value of these kinds of instruments
although I'd say screwdrivers are easy
and lying is hard
so when watch the wine you're taking
them we can hear from Tom - well I think
what we do is we prosecute corporations
however ineffectively we prosecute them
and we send their officers to jail and
expect that to change their behavior
should we prosecute corporations more
vigorously I certainly think so but
that's a separate issue than whether a
corporation should be a person which is
what we are talking about should it have
the rights so that it's independent of
the liabilities of its stockholders and
so on
likewise should how have rights that are
independent in some sense of what the
programmer does or a particular behavior
did would have have been it was it
correct for example to unplug hell long
enough to get through the air canopy
pull out some modules and put her back
in maybe that would have worked and the
point is a good defense lawyer would
have gotten hayloft
yeah exactly
well I would just add that capital
punishment for a program is a little bit
more acceptable because you can always
just turn it back on the leader
well if Nathan's corrected its back in
the same state so so you're asking
whether or not computers you're asking
whether or not computers have the same
basis as human beings in terms of if
we're going to evaluate whether they're
intelligent or neither
right so you should separate them not
not entirely I guess I would just say
that the only standards we have for
evaluating computer intelligence are our
own basis which is human intelligence
and we may have to come up with new
ideas about what it means to be
intelligent as our computers get smarter
I mean maybe Nell has already reached
some thresholds that we don't understand
yet and someday Nell will be in the
history books or Watson will be in there
in a way that we go really was something
about it and it's hard to know except
maybe retrospectively about where we are
in that curve but we tend to just use
the human standards because that's what
we have right exactly yes right in front
over here
like all the intelligence yes I want to
say I think must have hung around with
Lisa repetitiously on CMU before he
wrote that book but start saying that I
actually think that there are some very
interesting ways in which biological
Hardware conveys advantage and the
analogy here that I'd like to think
about is if you think about a computer
chip you have in some cases a hundred
billion transistors and every single one
of those transistors is effectively
identical to the next and Intel spends a
great deal of time and money developing
ways of ensuring this identical this
feature of chips that every transistor
is identical some there's a lot of work
including work from my own lab
indicating that individual neurons are
in some way uses an analogy like
snowflakes every neuron is a little bit
different even from its neighbor even
neurons that are allegedly of the same
type if you give them exactly the same
input you don't get the same output now
the question is is that is that a
feature or a bug is that something that
is to be overcome by collecting activity
from lots of neurons and sort of
averaging away this variability or could
you find a way to harness
that variability and some of the work
that we've done indicates it that at
least we're not sure that the brain
itself actually does this but at least
we can find a way to harness the
variability that we see from one neuron
to the next in a way that allows
populations of neurons to represent more
information to do to form certain
computations more efficiently than if
you had this sort of you know chip like
a model of neurons where every neuron
was identical to each other so I think
it's a feature it may have consequences
it may have some negative consequences
in terms of my ability to you know add
six digit numbers or a string of ten six
digit numbers rapidly but I but I'm
willing to pay that price I'm willing to
you know give up some of those kinds of
features for the kinds of capabilities
that we have as humans in it it's it's
leading towards prediction and a better
representation of the stimulus and
therefore allow us to predict what that
stimulus is going to how that stimulus
is going to behave in the in the near
future I'm sorry that actually there
would have to be the last question but I
will invite everyone to go into the
reception area we can talk more to the
panelists second of all I invite
everyone to come visit Carnegie Mellon
as Gary mentioned it's changed a lot
probably since we were there there's a
lot of amazing things that we could all
show you and we'd love to show you and
Pittsburgh's also change and there's
lots of amazing new things to do there
as well and finally I want to thank
everyone so much for coming and we're
very flattered that such a great turnout
so have a great night
you